ASSOCIATES ACTUALLY SUGGESTING
THAT SHE IS A UNITED STATES
VETERAN BEING GROOMED TO BE AN
AGENT OF RUSSIA.
AN ALLOCATION THERE IS ZERO
EVIDENCE, NONE WHATSOEVER.
ZERO BASIS IN REALITY.
BUT LISTEN TO THIS.
>> I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO BE
TWO PARTS AND IT'S GOING TO BE
2016.
DON'T VOTE FOR THE OTHER GUY.
DON'T VOTE FOR THE OTHER GUY, OR
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU IN THE
FLASHING VIDEOS THAT APPEAR AND
DISAPPEAR AND THEY ARE ON THE
DARK WEB AND NOBODY CAN FIND
THEM.
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE THEM AND
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE THAT PERSON
DO HORRIBLE THINGS.
THEY ARE ALSO GOING TO DO
THIRD-PARTY AGAIN.
I'M NOT MAKING ANY PREDICTIONS.
BUT I THINK THEY'VE GOT THEIR
EYE ON SOMEBODY CURRENTLY IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
AND OUR GROOMING HER TO BE THE
THIRD PARTY CANDIDATE.
SHE'S A FAVORITE OF THE
RUSSIANS.
THEY HAVE A BUNCH OF SITES AND
BOTS AND OTHER WAYS OF
SUPPORTING HER THUS FAR.
>> Sean: RESPONDED IN THE
RECENT VIDEO CALLING OUT
CLINTON'S REPEATED LIES ON FOR
SOME POLICY
,
FOREIGN POLICY FAILURES.
>> HILLARY CLINTON, YOUR FOREIGN
POLICY HAS BEEN A DISASTER FOR
OUR COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
RESULTED IN THE DEATH AND INJURY
OF SO MANY OF MY BROTHERS AND
SISTERS IN UNIFORM, DEVASTATED
ENTIRE COUNTRIES, MILLIONS OF
LIVES LOST.
YET DESPITE THIS DAMAGE YOU HAVE
DONE TO OUR COUNTRY AND THE
WORLD, YOU WANT TO CONTINUE YOUR
FAILED POLICY DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY THROUGH THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE.
IT IS TIME FOR YOU TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE DAMAGE YOU
CAUSED, AND IT'S LONG PAST TIME
FOR YOU TO STEP DOWN FROM YOUR
THRONE SO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
CAN LEAD WITH A NEW FOREIGN
POLICY, WHICH WILL ACTUALLY BE
IN THE INTEREST OF AND BENEFIT
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE
WORLD.
>> Sean: JOINING US THAT WITH
THE REACTION, CONGRESSWOMAN,
2020 CANDIDATE, WAR VETERAN
HERSELF TULSI GABBARD.
CONGRESSWOMAN, FIRST, THANK YOU
FOR SERVING YOUR COUNTRY.
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
AND A LOT OF YOUR FELLOW
DEMOCRATS, THEY MAY BE A LITTLE
AFRAID OF ME.
I DON'T KNOW WHY.
I'M A NICE GUY.
BUT THANK YOU FOR COMING IN.
SHE'S BASICALLY ACCUSING YOU OF
BEING A TRAITOR.
SAYING YOU ARE BEING GROOMED TO
BE THE AGENT OF THE SOVIET UNION
WITH NO EVIDENCE.
I ALWAYS COMPLAIN REPUBLICANS
ARE CALLED RACIST, SEXIST,
XENOPHOBIC, ISLAMOPHOBIC, THEY
WERE DIRTY AIR AND WATER.
SLANDER IS A BIG DEAL TO ME.
YOUR REACTION?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I'M PROUD TO
WEAR THE UNIFORM OF THIS
COUNTRY.
I HAVE SERVED AS A SOLDIER FOR
16 YEARS, STILL SERVE AS A MAJOR
IN THE ARMY NATIONAL GUARD TODAY
AND HAVE DEPLOYED IT TWICE TO
THE MIDDLE EAST SERVING IN
COMBAT AND LIKE EVERY OTHER
COMBAT VETERAN HAS SEEN
FIRSTHAND THE TERRIBLY HIGH
HUMAN COST OF WAR.
MY JOB IN IRAQ IN 25 DOWLING
ZERO FIVE, THE VERY FIRST THING
I DID EVERY SINGLE DAY WAS A
HEART-WRENCHING TASK OF GOING TR
HEART-WRENCHING TASK OF GOING TU
HEART-WRENCHING TASK OF GOING TH
NAME BY NAME EVERY LIST OF AMERI
NAME BY NAME EVERY LIST OF AMERA
NAME BY NAME EVERY LIST OF AMERN
CASUALTY AND INJURY THAT
OCCURRED IN THE PREVIOUS
24 HOURS.
THOSE OF US WHO HAVE SEEN THIS
TERRIBLY HIGH HUMAN COST OF WAR,
WE FIGHT FOR PEACE.
WE ARE NOT PACIFISTS.
WE KNOW UNFORTUNATELY WAR IS
NECESSARY TO FIGHT OUR COUNTRY.
WE SEE THAT WAR SHOULD BE A LAST
RESORT.
WHAT IS SO CONCERNING THAT WHAT
HILLARY CLINTON IS DOING HERE IN
CASE SHE IS NOT ONLY CALLING ME
A TRAITOR, SHE IS NOT ONLY
TRYING TO SMEAR MY CHARACTER,
SHE'S SENDING A WARNING OUT TO
EVERY VETERAN, EVERY SINGLE
AMERICAN, ANYONE WHO STANDS UP
THE WARMONGERING FOREIGN
POLICIES THAT REALLY ARE HER
LEGACY, THAT HAVE BEEN SO
DESTRUCTIVE AND COSTLY TO MY
BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN UNIFORM,
BECAUSE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS, AND
BECAUSE OF SO MUCH DAMAGE IN THE
WAR.
THIS IS WHAT'S SO DANGEROUS.
>> Sean: I'M TIRED OF
POLITICIZING WAR.
WE SEND THESE KIDS TO GO FIGHT,
BLEED, DIE, THEN IT IS
POLITICIZED.
I WANT THE NEXT GENERATION OF
WEAPONRY, DEFENSIVE, OFFENSIVE,
WE DON'T HAVE TO SEND OUR
NATIONAL TREASURE, OUR SONS AND
DAUGHTERS TO FIGHT ANYMORE,
BECAUSE THERE IS NO POLITICAL
WILL TO WIN IT, RULES OF
ENGAGEMENT UNDER OBAMA WERE
INSANE IN MY VIEW.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
WE DID HAVE SOMETHING CALLED THE
RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
OKAY?
IT WAS USED, THE BOOK
INFORMATION ACCORDING TO THE
GRASSLEY-GRAHAM MEMO, THE BULK
OF INFORMATION TO OBTAIN FISA
WARRANTS ON CARTER PAGE.
HE'S COOPERATED WITH OUR
INTELLIGENCE SERVICES EVERY TIME
HE WENT ABROAD.
THAT DOSSIER WAS FULL OF LIES,
EVEN IF IT'S AN UNVERIFIABLE
DOSSIER.
I HAVE NO IDEA IF ANY OF IT IS
TRUE.
B CHRISTOPHER
THAT WOULD BE CHRISTOPHER
STEELE.
WE HAVE FOUR INVESTIGATIONS INTO
DONALD TRUMP.
NO EVIDENCE OF TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DNC
PAYING FOR THAT RUSSIAN DOSSIER
FULL OF LIES?
>> LET ME SAY THIS.
INTERFERENCE IN OUR ELECTIONS IT
SHOULD BE A CONCERN OF EVERY
AMERICAN BECAUSE OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF ENSURING OUR
DEMOCRACY REMAINS STABLE.
AND THAT VOTERS HAVE FAITH IN
THE VOTES THAT WE CAST IN OUR
DEMOCRACY.
I'VE SAID THIS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
FOR THOSE DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS WHO MAY BE CONCERNED
ABOUT INTERFERENCE, LET'S
ACTUALLY PROTECT OUR DEMOCRACY
BY ENSURING WE HAVE PAPER
BALLOTS WERE VOTER VERIFIED
PAPER BACKUPS TO MAKE SURE IF
ANYONE COMES IN AND ACTUALLY TRY
TO MANIPULATE THE VOTES WE CAST
IN THESE ELECTIONS THAT THAT CAN
BE AUDITED, THAT WE HAVE A PAPER
RECORD OF THE VOTE.
>> Sean: I LIKE THAT IDEA.
>> I INTRODUCED LEGISLATION OF
SECURING AMERICAN ELECTIONS ACT
AND THOSE WHO ARE SAYING
INTERFERENCE, INTERFERENCE -- DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT.
PAST MY LEGISLATION.
MAKE SURE OUR VOTES, THE VOTES
OF EVERY AMERICAN ARE PROTECTED
AND WE ACTUALLY
OUR DEMOCRACY IS PROTECTED.
>> Sean: YOU ARE WATCHING ADAM
SCHIFF OR THREE YEARS, TELLING
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT THEY
HAVE EVIDENCE OF TRAP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION AND THE MUELLER REPORT
SAID THAT'S NOT TRUE.
NOW HE'S BEHIND CLOSED DOORS AND
THIS SECRET IMPEACHMENT HEARING.
I'M GOING TO READ TO YOU AND PUT
IT UP ON THE SCREEN WHAT
NEWT GINGRICH FORWARDED
BILL CLINTON, THE FULL HOUSE OF
VOTE AUTHORIZING THE ENTRY.
EVERY STEP OF THE ENTRY THIS
DEFINING
SCOPE.
WE KNOW THEY GRANTED COEQUAL
SUBPOENA POWER, THEY ALSO
ALLOWED SUBPOENAS TO BE THE
SUBJECT TO LEVEL AT THE REQUEST
OR OF THE CHAIR THE RANKING
MEMBER, THEY AFFORDED THE RIGHT
OF THE PRESIDENTS OPPOSING
OPPOSING COUNSEL TO SIT ON ALL
HEARINGS.
THE PRESIDENT'S COUNSEL ALLOWED
TO ADMIT EVIDENCE IN THE CASE
FOR THE PRESIDENT'S COUNSEL HAD
THE RIGHT TO CROSS-EXAMINE AND
RECOMMEND THE WITNESS LIST.
NOW ARE YOU GOING TO TELL ME
SUPPORT THE SECRET HEARING WILL
REPUBLICANS CAN'T HAVE ACCESS TO
NOT EVEN A TRANSCRIPT?
OR DO YOU THINK IT SHOULD BE
DONE THOUGH A NEW GREAT CRINGE
NEWT GINGRICH DID
IT FORWARD IN BILL CLINTON?
>> I THOUGHT IT SHOULD BE A
TRANSPARENT PROCESS BUT I LONG
EXPRESSED MY CONCERN ABOUT GOING
THROUGH IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS
IN A VERY, VERY PARTISAN WAY
BECAUSE IT WILL ONLY FURTHER
TEAR APART AN ALREADY DIVIDED
COUNTRY.
MY INTEREST AND CONCERN IS FOR
THE WORLD BEING OF OUR COUNTRY
AND DEMOCRACY MOVING FORWARD.
I THINK THERE ARE AREAS OF
CONCERN THAT WERE RAISED AROUND
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT HAPPEN
BETWEEN TRUMP AND THE UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT, WHICH IS WHY I
SUPPORTED THE INQUIRY.
I THINK THAT ENTRY NEEDS TO BE
DONE IN A VERY NARROWLY FOCUSED
WAY, AND IT MUST BE DONE
TRANSPARENTLY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THOSE CLOSED DOORS.
WE AS MEMBERS OF CONGRESS DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO THE INFORMATION
THAT'S BEING SHARED.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DESERVE TO KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THE
FACTS ARE, WHAT THE EVIDENCE IS
BEING PRESENTED AS THIS INQUIRY
GOES ON.
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION, WHY DO
YOU THINK UKRAINE AND CHINA
WOULD EVER GIVE HUNTER BIDEN WHO
HAD NO EXPERIENCE WITH EITHER
COUNTRY, A BILLING AND FIVE FROM
CHINA TEN DAYS AFTER HE FLEW
THERE WITH HIS COUNTRY.
NO EXPERIENCE OF PRIVATE EQUITY,
NO EXPERIENCE IN UKRAINE OR OIL,
GAS, ENERGY.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT HUNTER
BIDEN MADE ALL OF THAT MONEY?
WHAT WAS THE MOTIVATION OF
UKRAINE AND CHINA, CONGRESS
WOMAN?
>> THOSE ARE QUESTIONS ONLY
HUNTER BIDEN CAN ANSWER.
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU SUSPECT?
SOUNDS LIKE TO BUY FAVOR.
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS.
>> HUNTER BIDEN IS A GROWN MAN.
HE CAN BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
HIS OWN ACTIONS.
>> Sean: DOES THAT CONCERN YOU
THAT SOMEBODY WITH NO
EXPERIENCES, THE SON OF THE
SECOND MOST POWERFUL PERSON IN
THE COUNTRY GOT MILLIONS AND HAD
NO EXPERIENCE.
DOES THAT CONCERN YOU?
>> I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT EXAMPLES --
BE WHEN NOT ASKING YOU --
CONGRESSWOMAN, DOES THAT CONCERN
YOU HE GOT ALL OF THAT MONEY
WITH NO EXPERIENCE?